let's all welcome the new co-host of the
top
[Applause]
so it's Marie Osmond what do you think
of your new co-host I'm grateful every
time she's at the table she fits right
in she has so much life experience and
so much warmth and so I can't wait
stories like obviously being the newbie
I only got to see her in increments as
you know when she guest her but we did
say it she mentioned on the show we got
a chance to hang out in Vegas one night
at this party and we just kind of
wandered and would she like to turn
she was just what she lived you know
what it is somehow she was so real
because she was old real and I really
appreciate it yeah all right what advice
do you have for Marie but she's really
been here someone need to give her
advice but my dad sleep plan is working
say I work my way through Marie to get
to Donnie he's working out or Allen or
many of the Osmonds right but I get
through Marie this team is a family and
a very close-knit family and you're
losing a family member so how hard is
that I think because Sarah called me to
do this show in the beginning you know
but she's my neighbor you know I'm she's
still very much always be here she'll
always be here nobody leaves here you're
here in spirit
the chair is always open you can always
come back you know so she'll always be
here we'll be staking out it's Sharon
house you always have something big for
the fall and now with Marie are you
planning are you cooking up something
really really good
you could be cooking okay just can't
tell you what to say yeah we can't say
anything we can't say anything but it's
gonna be here mm-hmm watch out for
season 10 to the ninth season team all
right um
since Murray's a singer is there a
chance that you all will do anything and
in Halloween especially you know come on
Sharon I'd like to host that episode
okay don't ask me nothin cuz I can't
hold water okay I was gonna tell you
something no I'm no don't talk take the
camera off of me
[Music]